I'm a data scientist at BARC which is a
subscription service that provides dog
poison treats on a monthly basis we
provide very fun and weird toys and
treats this past month because it was
October we had Halloween games it was
Franken toys which were toys if it
sticks together in different ways and
they create different weird things
almost like that scene from Toy Story
one with Sid with all those weird like
things I put together not as gruesome
but very different switch for me and so
I'm really enjoying working with bark
and dogs instead of working with
patients a lot more fun yeah so today
we're talking about oh and we're hiring
so right now I can only have data
analyst positions but in q1 we're gonna
have more of the data scientist position
just because we do most of our business
and q4 is kind of crazy for us and so
we'd end up hiring q4 so much but q1
will be ramping up our hiring practices
again so if you go to the github page
you'll get something like this you can
just hit this open and collab which
we'll be doing together let's see if it
wants to work okay so this is the data
science challenge so this is when I was
in the healthcare when I was in
healthcare we had a lot of people
applying for our data science positions
and I would go through and for a while
we have challenges I need my personal
things I'm not really in favor of them
anymore
people still do give them and so now
just even if you don't like them
yourself to do that and so I want to go
through four aspects of them which I
find that people tend to have the most
trouble with and how to actually do them
in a way that's more in it or it's just
a better way of doing it all right at
least in my view is a better way so take
everything I say with a grain of salt
there's all based on personal experience
through kind of probably around two to
three hundred challenges that I've
evaluated so this is a data set that's
freely available and downloadable
is anyone not familiar with city bike
city bike right you take a bike bike for
it up to 30 or 45 minutes depending on
whether
you have a subscription and then you put
it back in the bike stand so is duration
start climbing they'd stop time today
the station names the ID the
latitude/longitude the bike ID what type
of user they are
what's the europe earth and you do this
for every single trip going back a
couple of years so it's a lot of data
relatively quickly
so hopefully let's see let's connect
allocate so I would assume so you can
check right it's a nice thing about this
will find out so this is just running
everything's all that it's just
downloading everything now I don't think
I'll be running most of the code over
here yeah so the first part is working
with people because they want to
simulate what data will look like in the
real world whoever the things I've seen
people do I can you literally have to
manually go in and screw over the data
in order to make it happen that way cuz
it never happens that way naturally but
they still do so well so you always want
to question the dam so one of the
variables that you look in the beginning
was this DF dia
so we're testing the first part so we're
doing four things so if the first one we
can be talking about is this finding
trip data so in this DF data your task
is to find all the different problems
with it so some of them are just natural
to the data this is how the data came
there are some issues with it and most
of them are things that I created so
there are about twelve different
problems with the data and so I would
say why don't we spend the next ten
minutes everybody can hopefully maybe
find someone if you want repair yourself
a more free - you're welcome - but maybe
find a partner to work with or - and
really try to find what the problems in
the data are see if you can spot them
hopefully I'll be able to pull up a list
of what they are
yeah and let me know you have any
questions
so roughly there's at least ten maybe
twelve different issues I put in the
data or so
let me see if I can do it this way
so for anyone who arrived late if you
just go to this if you go to the
thoughts are called the this talk on the
PI data schedule website it has linked
to the repo which you're going to get
here
[Music]
yeah
so for anyone who just at the top of the
top of the page it tells you what each
of this is from the website it just
tells you each of the gerbils are so
like trip duration is in seconds user
type is customer or subscriber gender
zero one or two so those are not like
errors this is this is what you're given
so I guess gender of 0 that's just
unknown because you always have a gender
yeah
[Music]
all right so I'm gonna go 15 minutes so
I don't want to so as incentives for
swag there are stickers from work so we
have fun sings on them every day is a
second chance to pee on something the
world is my dog park you're just living
in it have a Great Dane we have one
mutts are my mantra sticker so
contributors get stickers right so who
wants to tell me and just remember if
you contributed and I'll give you after
cuz it's gonna otherwise I'll take quite
a while to go back and forth can people
stickers so who wants to what our issues
that people found yeah so I'm just gonna
go back to my cheat sheet of things that
actually did so I can check them off yes
so we have right we have Grover it's not
a bike right so yeah right so we have
some of the right these are the bike IDs
right bike IDs right not all we're
numbers okay well yeah
yes all right
right say it again yes yes so yes
because it definitely isn't that that
was the right if there's once but there
is an fun factor is it no there is no
bike station and that's riff right so
and if you check actually in a matches
of n latitude and longitude match so it
actually is in the Hudson River but
that's not a real location that one
would one of the trick ones I'm
surprised someone found that one great
yeah yeah um yes
not my not mine though that was in the
dataset itself I did not do that one but
yes that's so that's an interesting
thing in the data so you'll see yeah
what else
yes so right so right there zero one two
and it's fine if people the last people
but when one person has something and no
one else has that that's probably a
mistake right but why they store these
objects right because if you try to do
right if you try to do like to daytime
right if you did so it's DF data that
start time or actually you have to that
story so it's PD duck to daytime wants
to do this right and I try this it
shouldn't work there should be hours I
was on the stop time stop time
yeah some of these are invalid date
times so yeah so some of them are just
invalid right there invalid stop times
what I put the times as they're just
like nut so yeah they're just in
Valentine they're just they cannot exist
I think what was it it was I think they
yeah like February 30th or something
like that so right so it looks like and
it it formats correctly but this will
give you the error so they're different
ways of getting around that but yeah
right negative trip duration how would
you go about fixing that
so that's a way of getting rid of it but
how what else could you do
well yeah so someone I heard someone say
something over here you could
recalculate them yeah right because you
have the start time in the end time you
could rewrite you should check to make
sure because they give you will start
time and end time and then the calculate
in theory trip duration is calculated
from that so sure negatives are a quick
way to be like nope that's obviously
wrong but then you can regenerate them
assuming you believe that start in the
stop times yes which is probably
impossible maybe possible but probably
impossible yeah so I was one of mine
yeah so that's an outlier but once again
that wasn't one of mine that was had so
the theory it because there are like you
see there are some there are some
traditions which are ridiculously long
I'm not sure what that is because in
theory if you just forget to put like
four to take the bike out I guess I'd
never return it it's good I guess they
don't have a way in the system to just
say that bike is lost so I guess they
just keep putting it out but then it
does have you'll see they will have
still have a end time and because in
theory if they never finished the trip
they shouldn't have an end station but
they do so it's weird so I'm not sure
what that means but that was not that's
a problem with the data not a problem
from like I then up to that problem in
never yes it's problem with the data yes
so those are it definitely outliers and
so that's a problem you put when you let
people put whatever they want in people
put whatever they want in anyone else
anything else this people found right
and what it anywhere else find anything
we brought the stations well
Semiramis I'm sure some of the station
names will station could be there well
what do you mean the same okay so you'll
see right so hold on where's my mouse so
we do here right so we have DF data
station name let's say let's say it was
star station me
let's go that star station name right so
we can check of their no or accidentally
na right and this tells us that some are
there's 114 nulls okay but and I've seen
this in multiple tests like there also
could be yeah it's equal to none but
it's a string none right so that's an
invalidation name but it's read it as a
string not as an na and so writes a pom
or when your stuff like oh yeah yeah I
said I put empty strings in there there
should be some empty strings I might I
might taking them out but also those are
problematic so you have to be careful
about those as well if I didn't put them
in okay I guess there are just any more
I guess I took them out but yeah so
they're close to be empty strings and in
addition to obviously the null values
which is just they exist because those
are the no those are original the data I
added the nuns and the well in theory at
the empty strings I guess I didn't add
the empty strings anything else people
found let's see so right we have
negative trip durations oh they were so
trip durations don't always match the
start and stop times so that was also
one of them I switch to starting top
times that the start time was the exact
same as the stop time so it's at
beforehand but it's exact same time and
it's only for stage so in theory that's
possible but if they're not the same
station ID that's impossible right for
the same station ID in theory it's
possible cuz you could literally do it
in a second but now it invalid stop
times move something to move some of
them into the Hudson I changed some of
the station names to various versions
no oh and this was another word one
their same bike is in multiple locations
at the same time so you have to what's
it not all these were meant to fine I
just try to make some live really hard
one so yeah it's the same ID and the
same time but in completely different
locations right right and the some of
the bike IDs were Grover or right like L
zeros l0o and now once I trade that one
and then one person has different gender
category great so if nothing else that
should have given you a good
appreciation of what the data is
actually like so that's a small sample
of the data that's as DF data the actual
data is DF CB which should also be
located which also should be in your
memory at this point so I want you to do
now is now that you feel you have some
idea of what the data is let's work on
creating an outline and this feels very
like college essay ish and it is but
it's a problem because I feel like
people jump into these data challenges
straight into the code so I spend 20
hours on their EDA they'll have nothing
to show for it besides for some really
pretty pretty plot and to be honest I've
done this myself and the most people
that take two minutes on the modeling
and then surprisingly the person
reviewing it is not happy with it
because there's no real story involved
and that's one thing I really want to
take away is that a data science and
pretty much any type of this thing cuz
this as a science allenge is very
artificial but you will always have to
do stuff like this as a data scientist
as an analyst for work all the time you
have to tell a story with what you're
presenting so what you're giving back
should be a story to have a beginning a
middle and an end and should be
compelling story and so that's why you
should always create an outline for
anything you're going to do especially
comes to these challenges so here's the
challenge right using the citibike data
set predict how long the ride will be
given the information available when the
rider starts their ride and so they'll
say you should spend about five hours
working on this challenge please make
sure to unclear any clearer and clearer
include clear data analysis and
visualization well-documented
and interpretive all code appropriate
use of statistical machine learning
modules and explanation of the results
so this is in theory this is the made-up
test that I'm giving you so I'm actually
not going to do most of this tasks but
for the first thing what I want you to
do now is write an outline for this so
over here are the four categories
there's going to be an ad a section a
data really
in ship section a modeling section and a
result summary section what I want you
to do is now write for each one of these
what you plan on doing in that section
so this should take you about 5-10
minutes and just write okay
for the EBA we're gonna make this plot
and this pot in this pot because you so
the full data set is the exact same
variables but there's just a lot more of
the data and it's cleaner to some degree
so I want you to do EDA data
relationship so that's between different
variables modeling like what Molly
you're going to choose and then the
results summary of how you going to
explain the model and so what we want
you to do for each one of these is spend
right probably about a paragraph not
more than a paragraph for each one and
also give it time estimate so you have
five hours I would say try to have your
time at up to four hours for like you're
gonna let cell EDA will take me an hour
modeling will take me an hour and all
the stuff will take me different of time
so have it add up to about four hours
four hours and change and that should be
your good estimate to start off with so
let's go with your partner just go into
it and into discussion and just figure
out what you want in these different
sections and it will come back about ten
minutes
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the
[Music]
okay let's turn this back on let's come
back together so does anyone want to
share so hopefully you were not looking
at what I was already because I was
trying to write ridiculous things on
purpose like histogram of bike IDs it's
real helpful anyone want to share what
they did for with what their plan is for
EDA just in terms of the time and the
time for things I want to plot
what
so that's a great question that's
something today that was good enough if
wasn't brought up as we'll discuss at
the end so in general they will usually
be very specific if they do not want you
to use external data sets if you want to
use an external data set and it was not
mentioned one way or the other always
ask ask questions be like do you mind if
I use this data set right cuz in
addition to that maybe whether like if
it rains
maybe that's important or snow yeah I
and I notice ooh MIT is and I like to
show you that later where I'm pretty
sure it is
but that's not in this data set and so
you that probably is very predictive and
so you wanna in there real data science
like if you're doing this for work
obviously you pull the data in because
why wouldn't you but for a challenge
sometimes they do not want to use a
kernel data for a variety of reasons so
never hurts to ask
so that's a great question also and
that's for data science challenge I
would use whatever you have I would not
really so much unless it's really really
ethically like unsound like using gender
to predict ride length doesn't sound
like it's possible to use f for evil
purposes but it isn't inherently a bad
thing right so I wouldn't really worry
about that but for this I would yeah
unless it's something that really like
it feels wrong to use there's no reason
not to use it right that's a great thing
yeah so you have that right that's a
great plot anyone else
sure that's entry yeah so that's yes the
problem hmm yeah that's interesting yeah
mm-hmm right so I mean so two things
what are you getting through the day
relationships which is great we could
definitely jump into those as well too
that's something that like be aware of
like how long it will take you to make a
certain kind of plot so that plot
especially if you're really not up on
geo planning that's going to thank you a
couple hours by itself to get that
actually to work and be nice because
remember everything I didn't and we'll
come back to this because the next
section is going to be actually creating
one of these or to a couple of these
plots you have to be realistic in what
you can do in the time frame you have
like they say five hours and like a lot
of people say oh just ignore that five
hours I would say no try to do you came
in five hours and then if you have time
come back and do more so think what you
can actually reasonably do in five hours
because in a business case they will
you'll have a limited time you will have
let's say a week to do a project or some
X amount of time through a project you
cannot be like well you cannot ask for
more time simply because you want to a
prettier plot right so understand how
long it'll take you to do things when
you're setting up doing them this is why
I want to have this outline because
that's a great first inclination that's
a really interesting plot that if it
takes you five hours to do it you've
spent all your time on something on one
thing and they're gonna be like great I
don't think the person actually built
the model instead right yeah I know this
week that was a great idea for a plot
but just keep that in mind and also in
terms of the data relationships also
that they anything that they were
thinking of doing that was different or
interesting or standard yeah
so does anyone here use citibike so
right and so here's where a little
domain knowledge gonna help you what can
anyone who's a city bike and tell me the
difference between a subscriber and a
user and a non subscriber yes right so
if you are not your subscriber you get
45 minutes per ride if you're not
subscribed be only at 30 minutes before
they charge you more so that's
interesting like it'll definitely make a
difference because you'll see that like
most there's tons of rides and like 30
to 40 or 50 minutes all right 40 like
around that time is fiscally because
they get charged more so that's where
like so for city bike you can find this
domain knowledge but like if you come
with your own domain knowledge even just
a small piece of information can really
help you and so they usually they will
not expect you to know that coming in
especially because I mean city bike in
theory it's bald not enough but for
something more esoteric like marketing
or something that they might you're not
you should expect it to but if you know
it show that you know it like cuz it
never hurts to show domain knowledge
right and so what I will say to that is
that's a great inclination and a great
way to at the other day there's also
this I'm going to repeat this a couple
times that I think it's important it's
meant to be a story so definitely if you
if they're very quick plots to do make
them and then delete all the
uninteresting ones from your actual
report right because you don't like no
one wants to see 50 histograms that's
just not interesting things to say you
can write a line like obviously if
you're two of sowing three histograms
that are interesting I will assume you
did all the ones that are showing me
only the interesting results right and
if nothing's interesting right the
histograms were not interesting or you
know throw a throwaway line in there so
they know you looked at them and
assuming they actually are not
interesting like if there's something
like don't miss something
don't assume there's nothing there and
just write something about it that's
obviously much worse if there's
something there you just say oh there is
nothing there but yeah definitely once
again it's a story so it should be as
short or as long as it needs to be well
know if it's not I would say you can
write that like I look at the histograms
and only show you the ones that were
interesting right like don't I don't
need this [ __ ] I don't like it's not
like that math that's right we have to
show your effort I'd if it's
uninteresting and you wouldn't present
it like think of really think of this as
story if you would not present this in
the story don't present it here you can
definitely write the line that I here's
what I did that I did this in this
because of XY and Z right so I chose
these three histograms because they had
interesting data which will I'm
displaying them that's a valid way of
doing it and that shows not only did you
look at the data we then thought about
the data that was actually interesting
because nothing is worse then you you
you which call you're sending me
something that's I it like 300 lines
around 300 cells long I like every
single possible thing you could possibly
plot you're just letting the kitchen
sink at something a report think about a
report like it should be one to two
write or say like what's in
it went a go back to this college essay
analogy one to two to three pages long
is how long the report should be someone
that someone should be able to read your
report in five minutes or less and get
what you're saying
right not run the code but they should
be able to like just rerun through it in
five minutes and it should be cohesive
it should tell a single story and it
should like build up to something so
that's the way I want you to think about
or that's why I think about them and
when I see those kind of reports it just
makes sense and think about also think
about the report you'd want to see sure
you've got you you know all these
techniques and you really want to show
that you know all them right it's more
impressive if I you always show that you
know which one to use in the right case
I find that much more interesting then
showing me you can do everything showing
me that you know not the only you can do
everything or that you know the right
thing to do is a much more interesting
and much more it's a much rarer skill
Yeah right that's a great thing also I
didn't want to talk about what kind of
model they would use so this was meant
to be a joke and I'm gonna say this I
would be the [ __ ] if you use a neural
network as your first model I am NOT
going to read the rest of your thing
because especially for this data set
like why using a neural network in
general like unless the cup that you're
applying to is like neural networks are
us don't frame your own network because
like they're not a they're pretty much
unexplainable there's another shop I
know there's line
no one ever can use them correctly they
make no sense anyone who doesn't really
understand them like they're not helpful
for the average person especially if
you're attending this to people who are
not data scientists they'll have no idea
what you're talking about the caveat
being and this is not for a design
challenge in certain companies you do
have to do them because it makes
everyone very happy when you do a neural
network even if it's not the right test
that's a very specific use case that
we're talking about here here we're
talking about something where you're
giving it to someone who in theory knows
what they're talking about and if they
see a neural network they will not care
remind you if you really think it's the
perfect model do it as your second model
show them you can do something besides
for a neural network yeah so I know you
haven't touched the data really at all I
mean besides looking at the trick data
anyone have ideas of what kind of model
they would want to run for this that's
perfectly valid one anything else random
forest anyone else
yeah well just regression road you can
always yeah yeah and she could also do
stuff like they were very I try to be
relatively vague on the test like the
writing time cuz like they give you
writing time in seconds but you can
maybe think about maybe you won't
actually do it in minutes or you know
hours and stuff like that or let's say
below 15 minutes or after 15 minutes
like you just won't do because it
probably doesn't matter if they're five
or a four minute ride it matters if
there are five in a ride or a 45-minute
ride probably and this is are all
different this is how you want to think
about these tasks like what makes sense
for me to do what's an interesting way
of approaching the data that's still in
the realm of what they're asking for and
then for the results summary I mean so
this is much harder to do at this point
and this is why it's gonna be vague it's
gonna be so you're gonna have some kind
of plots and analyses for the most part
but this is I wanted to put this here
because people always forget to do a
results summary they will do a results
they will give me something and then
maybe I'll throw an f1 score I don't
really care like that's not explaining
the results all you've done is write it
think about this like you ever see a TV
show or a movie right and like all the
actions they have that huge action scene
the action scene is not the last scene
in the movie right there's usually a
couple scenes after where everything
cools down and they have this sit by the
fireside or they go off for shwarma or
something like that right and that to me
well that's what your result summaries
meant to do it's meant to bring
everything back and be like here's what
we found
here's why I made sense here's why it
didn't make sense here's the problem
with one of these here's what I do if I
had more time which is always a great
because that's always a great way also
like if you if something you think is
really interesting if you don't have
time you can say here's why we live I
had more time so it shows that you
thought about these things
and you were going to do it and you
would do it but you were cognizant of
how much time it would take and so their
credit for not doing something which is
the best kind of credit to get right
just say you're gonna do and you get
credit for it
what's better so what type of analysis
do you think you'd want to do for this
given let's it cuz I mean spoiler what
I'm gonna give you at the end of this is
I'm gonna give you for the last test
we're actually going to be doing results
summary I'm going to give you
predictions
just going to give you the predictions
and the results I mean sorry the
predictions and the rationale durations
and you can have so you can have two
sets of data so how would you want to
actually
what would you want to do with that
that's a great thing
what else okay
right so you can see there's like and I
you didn't this is probably the hardest
to do at this point because I haven't
told you what you were getting but
that's what you want to be thinking as
these things is the prediction and the
results of the model is just the first
step
you didn't have to then finish the story
and tell me what it means and what I can
use it for and even if it's a bad model
if you tell me okay it's a bad model we
should go something simple or more
complicated or something just tell me
tell me so tell me a story right or like
took them do you know right to be
continued in part two I'd be interesting
writing like if I had like and then
we'll bring you in and they'll ask what
you would do next kind of thing like
have lead them on make them interested
in what you're saying okay so we've done
this right modeling part of it I mean
this outline so they have an outline of
how long things should take so now let's
do some EDA and date a relationship so
basically above outline create at least
one figure from both the EDA and data
relationship sections so it doesn't have
to be the ones who actually wrote if you
people said you thought hey that was a
great idea steal their plot perfectly
fine because I bet you you probably been
doing a slightly differently than
they're gonna do it so each figure
should be presentation ready before we
move on to the next one right it's in
very it's essential that a plot should
be self-contained before you keep going
to the next one the next one or the next
one just make each one as nice as it
needs to be before you go on write it
should be as understandable as possible
without any external externalities which
means make your labels let make your
labels mean something versus just like
x-axis y-axis not helpful right have a
legend have what's a title all these
things are essential to plots is any is
anyone who's heard of Pampas profiling
let's go with that okay good you haven't
heard so I can tell you so heinous
profiling this used to be like I love
pants profiling now I'll show you what
this is it's a package that came out I
don't want to came out but I found about
this a couple months ago
you've given a data set so this is the
result for the city bike data set so you
give it a data set
and you say give me a profile of it and
what it does is it outputs all of this
for you so tells you the information the
number of variables number of
observation how many missing duplicates
what type of things you have the
cardinality for each variable goes
through and tells you all this
information you can toggle the details
for it
you can see a histogram right you don't
have to do a single thing of work for it
and now did anyone find something
interesting in the birth here dataset
yet
I mean I'll spoil this one but they
don't know what the default value is for
birth year does anyone know now that the
default value is for birth year it's
1969 right or at least that's why I'm
assuming that's what that means right
because this is spiked there for no
reason unless it's the default value
which would make sense right because it
increases but familiar 99 is just huge
right so if you look at common values
right we could see that 1969 is 9 10 %
of the people were born in 1969 66,000
yeah right right but that they weren't
born then they were conceived then that
was the point right so we're 69 which
mean they shoulda been born in 70 right
but you can see right like all the other
years like if you look at 1970 it's not
even on this list in 1968 1969 is just
huge so this is panis profiling gives
you all this and it's no effort it is
because originally this talks when I
first used to give it half of it was
doing these things that's all gone now
because it does it for you and so and do
not befriend it gives you correlation to
gives you everything missing values it's
unbelievable it gives you samples just
because why not
and it's literally two lines of code the
code is literally like it's like import
panas profiling and then pandas
profiling like give me the report to
give you the data set and it's all this
stuff out for you all you have to do
it's the easiest thing in the world
so this is linked in the collab notebook
over here and here is the here's the
link to the actual Python package for it
and so take a look at that and don't be
afraid to use that like a good data
scientist is someone who uses their
tools so really you don't feel like
pretend you don't know it exists and be
like oh and like show how you calculate
these things you can link to the pandas
profiling results and just talk about
the interesting results that come out of
it you don't have to actually recreate
them you don't have to recreate the
wheel
someone did it for you already you don't
have to do it again right like you don't
have to recreate do how doing arrays and
data frames right because
this exists painters profiling exist you
don't have to do it by yourself but you
don't to do it yourself anymore so using
pandas profiling just to get a good look
at the data also so that's why Eevee is
probably not gonna be so important at
this point so try to figure out one or
two well yeah one EDA plot and then one
or two what's it called exploratory date
data relationship so we're looking at
two or more variables and so as a guide
this is a table from Burton's semiology
of graphics which is a very interesting
book on just graphic design and this is
actually specifically was I saw in Jake
van der classes who is the author who's
the primary contributor to Altair which
is a plotting library and Python 2019
talking about how to think about data
but pretty much he splits it into three
basic categories its quantitative or no
and nominal right so quantitative is
just your basic numerical data one two
three four five
ordinal is things that are ordered a
categorical right so like Likert scale
is ordered categorical or anything where
the relationship like good great bass
right that's ordered but it's
categorical but it's ordered and then
animal is unordered categorical data
right so different fruits are just on
order the categorical data and what he
shows is how this table is a measure of
how easy these things are to visualize
using the different different types so
position is great for everything size is
great for everything color value is
great for nominal or no it's not great
for quantitative value texture great
phenomenal not really great forward note
it's garbage for quantitative and just
this is a good guide for how to think
about plotting these different things
and then just for people use here are
some different libraries and just there
are sample plots you've met pot Lea plot
least Seabourn plot and I on out there
you pick your favorite the data
challenge is not the time to be learning
a new plotting library you should have
some of these tools under your belt and
just be popping them out cuz these
remember remember you have a limited
amount of time you have other things you
have to do with your life just pick
something you know and use that and so
so yeah so in the next let's say 10 15
minutes creating one EDA into data
relationship plots I try to make them as
pretty as possible yeah so go
also remember that the the data you want
is DFC be not DF data DF data was that
trick data DF CB is the actual valid
data so what should be loaded into
memory at this point also when you ran
those first cells this is the actual
this is the real data this is so
everything is the mistakes that were
inherent in the data are still inherent
in here like the 1969 stuff and the
person born in 1885 but all the other
weird stuff like the negative trip
duration stuff that's all removed
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay in the interest of time we're gonna
I'm so on right so because we're about
15 minutes left let's run through so
maybe want to be what they plotted like
I so I chose right so this is this is
using altair which I like a lot
I surely recommend it something to learn
not for the assignment challenge but
afterward if you like it because it's
relatively simple right this is the
entire code to create the plot and it
gives you nice tooltips and you can have
it's very and I'll show you more things
you can do with it in a second so what
do people do for either EDA or there are
there are other parts well let's see
then e1 get through making a plot a
fully-formed plot let's go that okay and
so anyone else fully make a fully form
that they're happy with at this point
okay so you had about 10 15 minutes you
can see right you can do one figure in
ten to fifteen minutes I'm not saying
and that understandable unreasonable and
this is the point right that like you
have to unlock your time beforehand so
be aware it's gonna take you 20 or 30
minutes to make a single plot and so we
want to make 10 plots sure obviously
just making slight variation to do that
way but it takes time you get lost in
the codon it's three hours later that's
a problem be aware of how long it takes
you to make these things so you have an
idea if I'm gonna make five plot it's
gonna take me an hour like Julie saying
I always have this idea oh it takes me a
couple minutes to make a plot five
minutes maybe no I look at the actual
ease right you want to look right I
didn't get the size right or the
formatting right here yet this is really
just using the based characteristics
yeah so anyone did anyone found anything
interesting in the relationships
[Music]
right that's right and so knowing how
that it is held rate just knowing that
that's also why I would not suggest
making those 1916 are people Nan's
because you want to split them out but
maybe put them as something else right
and so that's why it's important not to
just group them with all with everyone
else that's missing the birth year or
whatever it is because it tells you that
they did something specific the promise
obviously the people who were born in
1969 they get washed but there's nothing
to do about that yes that's interesting
anyone else find something interesting
so anyone do anything let's say about
weekdays versus weekends right so one
dude that's the point right there are
hundreds different plots you can do so I
just want to show so hold on when I
could find wherever my mouse is there it
is so we're gonna skip so over here I
have this is I will come back this in a
second but click on this link it's an
example for summaries so here is a
summary of my EDA for this thing so I'll
come back to these other parts later but
let's just scroll down and they just go
to the EDA table this is me doing
everything I could possibly think
upstairs let's say count versus trip
duration right so you can see that and
this is plot on a log scale which I
thought was more helpful as you can see
and so this is interactive so it's nice
right so most these people right are
attempt to be you know like twelve
minutes all these really times it very
short durations so we can scroll down so
I thought this interesting it's count
and trip duration as a function of
cumulative percentage of writers so you
can see that more than like what is this
twelve minutes is about sixty percent of
all people are twelve minutes or less
right and so you can see so you could
you don't have to plan a lot and this I
think is helpful for this kind of
analysis also so I just told you Oh
twelve minutes they'll be on average
twelve minutes or something like that
right they probably get you most of the
way there in terms of your modeling
and this is what it's meant to do do
things like this which i think is
helpful so this is the start date and
the count and so the orange ones are
weekends and the blue ones are weekdays
and so you could see right so definitely
right these weekends people don't ride
but like what happened over here which
is significant I'm assuming there was
raining or bad weather or was extremely
hot something in those days right so
here's we'd want to link in weather data
right oh that's interactive via or here
you have let's say the day of the week
and the average count here you have
hours of day right and the number of
people who ride the bikes then right so
you see right so there's this huge spike
over here right like seven eight like
the commuting times and back also you
know five six pm so also this big spike
Metro wide increases the rest of the day
also I guess these people even work
early it's interesting oh yeah you could
see so this is just this was other
analysis is looking for those find those
missing dates where you could see that
certain stations are very popular have
like 40,000 users and some of them have
like 11th Street and 43rd Avenue like
very few people use that station
apparently yes you can see it right
here's that birth year one the birth
year and the count of different writers
so yeah there's this also it's
interesting no yeah so my trip duration
you go sixteen do things like calculate
things you can like do the trip distance
and the trip duration and this is not
half of print for predicting trip to
trip duration but you something
interesting you plot could you'd expect
it to be there to be a relationship
between them have like trip duration
versus birth year I find it to be that
indicative but he goes to plot this
eight different ways and that's the
point you want to pick one or two things
do you think will be the most
informative and jump to those so we have
about 10 minutes left so I'm going to
skip this last section and so here's or
something you can play with on your own
so it's a model explanation in summary
cuz I want to give time for some
questions and some other just my musings
and thoughts at the end which is what I
called it so this goes back to my I'm
saying before a common mistake is just
to present your results with either just
a score or a confusion matrix but you
want to present more than that you
really want to tell a story of a figure
two and then why your model succeeded
where it failed what you would do next
what are your next steps exactly like
you were doing if this was part of your
actual job so
let's get to some musings and we'll
hopefully aside for questions so
structure your data science challenge
once in this comes back to its supposed
to be a story you should always start
with a summary and a readme your summary
should be pretty much the equivalent of
a blurb in a book it should be here's
the summary of what I was doing I'm
examining this data they brought just
here some interesting things about it 50
Freight you can have hyperlinks to link
to different figures right and this is
all this is this is in the github also
so you can find all these files there
there's less runners on Sunday and you
like have nice links to it so they can
like you're telling a story over here
and then nothing not right nothing's
really and nothing really correlates to
the trip duration which you can see and
then if there you don't have a section
on what the results were like I thought
I use a linear model and I found that it
worked well for let's say it accounted
for 80 percent of the data and I would
if I had more time that would do a
logistic regression right and that's a
good summary it should be a one
paragraph tell it more a couple
paragraphs telling me exactly what
you're going to do how you're going to
do it and what you got then you won't
have a readme which right because if if
the code doesn't run I can't use it
so it's something especially if it's
something weird about your code first of
all I never hurts to put down what
Packers are using and the dependencies
just in case to something weird but if
you're doing something weird with your
code let me know ahead of time and let
the person know ahead of time they're
like you're on Python 2 6 and old me
work on Python 2 6 for some reason
that's fine it's perfectly reasonable I
know if there's a good reason for it
because oh it uses this package which
doesn't exist they never upgrade it to 3
whatever that's fine just make it very
clear
so yes you want to have and I have an
example readme in summary so things to
keep in mind just like any presentation
spelling and formatting matter if I say
spelling mistakes especially more than
one it gives me it right away turns me
off of the candidate and you should
check for it so and there are things
that I do that already
there's spellcheck for Jupiter note box
it does automatic real time spell
checking you also have Jupiter black
which is a formatter which I get really
pretty formatting for all your codes you
don't have to know what the actual Pepe
rules are it does it for you it's really
nice so there's some other musing so
tell me a story which I've hopefully
drilled into at this point ask questions
if something is not clear in the
challenge and
questions they might specifically be
giving you vague instructions because
they want to see if you'll ask questions
right I mean I haven't done that but I
definitely know friends who have done
that who give data science challenges
because I want to make sure you're able
to communicate you're able to you know I
mean come back and say hey this makes no
sense or hey help me with this part of
the problem I explain and justify don't
randomly select an algorithm why did you
choose the algorithm why were your
choices valid or reasonable why do the
logistic regression make sense why
you're in a forest makes sense and it
could really be simply as it works for
this kind of like this is the data we
have random force is a good model for
this kind of data this is why I used it
that's perfectly reasonable right what
else would you try if you had more time
you're gonna have to answer these
questions later probably anyways
hopefully they will ask you about the
challenge and not just have you give it
to them and then it's a little white
random seeds always set your random
seeds for corn reproducibility I know
the kind of defeats all points of random
seeds but if specially not that well if
you will not run your code but if they
run your code and it produces something
completely different they're going to
call it the question everything you did
and so it's nice if you just say oh you
can always reproduce it using these
random seeds and tailor your response so
consider the Job Description and tell
your approach to match the skills you
need for the job if it's a very if it's
very heavy on an NL job spend most of
your time on the modeling if it's a very
heavy analysts job spend most your time
on the analysis beforehand right match
to what you're going for and also where
you are in the companies interview
process the earlier you are honestly the
less you really have to do if you're
like if they say they're using this as a
screening tool you should not be killing
yourself if they're using this as the
final set decide between unit and
another candidate you just kill yourself
especially if you want the job like kill
yourself or that thing right because
they're places which will do it and
they're assigned three minutes looking
at it just to make sure you know how
Python works and they don't care so if
you spend 20 hours making the prettiest
thing in the world it's kind of waste of
your time not theirs
so submitting our ipython notebook and
an HTML download Python notebook
sometimes don't work they have to send
it around the company and then someone
else where it has to start up a kernel
and stuff like that so send them an HTML
file right so this is an HTML file of my
of like of Jupiter notebook it shows
everything it's perfectly reasonable
it's clean it's easy dude use neural
networks we're just gonna go that just
don't use it and then create a portfolio
this is a great way to build up your
portfolio especially you can always ask
the company if they're fine with you
putting the project after you're done
with it on your own personal get up page
this is a great way to show people who
come to you afterwards who are hiring
you or you look trying to find more
about you these shows you the range of
things you're able to do personally and
I can it's more anecdotal evidence I
have no evidence I have no actual data
to back this up
but if I see something that says forked
from X I don't care about that repo
because I don't know how much work you
did versus how much that you've just
copied and I'm not gonna spend the three
hours comparing the repos to understand
oh you actually did significant changes
to what this other person did I assume
you just copied it and used it which is
fine but that doesn't impress me at all
same thing with classes if you're like
oh I took this class I assume you just
follow the instructions and did nothing
novel on your own so I'm going to ignore
those repos so you want the more repos
you have that are purely your code the
better it is and the more I'm gonna take
a look and notice right because I've
seen stuff we're just like class after
class after fork after fork don't care
about any of them and even if you can do
forking and do very undo a lot of
differences in the code copy the code
don't fork or make it very clear that
like this code was inspired by this
other person's thing but don't for kit
because fork just implies to me that a
you're gonna merge it back in especially
you're not merging it back in do not
fork it and so yeah that's kind of what
I'm trying to thought there but yeah so
copy the code copy it attribute to its
proper source but don't fork whose fork
implies to me that this is not your code
that's what implies which is fine but
I'm not gonna I'm not going to look at
it what I'm trying to look at who you
are as a person and as a programmer so
in terms of the grading rubric things
that matter and this is I'm definitely
missing things over here and this is
definitely the order will change
depending on who's looking at it what
they care about so does your code run
what is the ratio of text to code it
should be a lot of text and some code in
terms of like story right I want to see
a story that tells me it takes me
through every single step of the way you
want to be
a good communicator because
communication is key right there's a
adage in academia publish or perish in
data science it's very much tell me a
story
that's what I want to see what is the
ratio of text to code I should not just
be seeing black of code after block of
code after block of code it's
uninteresting and it doesn't tell me
anything and it doesn't also doesn't
tell me that you understand what you're
doing it just tells me you're able to do
it and you could have just been kind of
doing some copy pasta from Stack
Overflow which definitely happens and we
all do it but I want to understand that
yeah I want to know that you understand
what you're doing as well so that's why
the more you write about it the better
it is do you explain what significant
choices you made in while you made them
are there any spelling mistakes
these are code pythonic so people care
about that I tend not to care so much
and then just at the bottom here's just
a list of good news letters and data
science articles that I tend to get I
tend to read like half of these a week
if I can because they just come out so
frequently these are good some of them
have job listing some of them just
interesting things to talk about so yeah
so we have about literally a minute left
so I'm not going to make everyone say
for Q&A so I'll happy to say after
people have questions otherwise thank
you for your time
[Applause]